waves of the blue seas of the caribbean
roll onto the white sands and palm
tree-lined beaches
of the northern honduran coast
the small communities who inhabit this
biodiverse paradise
survive predominantly on the fish they
take from the waters
and the vegetables they grow
it looks like paradise but its beauty
and its location
has turned deadly for these people
the garifuna and afro-caribbean
population originally from the island of
saint vincent
who were evicted from their homes by the
british in the 1700s
have lived here and protected this land
for generations
but drug cartels palm oil manufacturers
and tourism developers want to take it
from them
and they're prepared to kill to do it
last summer for garafuna and a visitor
were abducted by armed men from a series
of houses in the village
amongst them the community's leader they
say
he was tortured at this house before
they were all taken away
none have been seen again it's assumed
they're dead
cesar now leads the community he told me
that drug cartels want the garifuna's
remote beaches to ship drugs to the
united states
while property developers want the
beachfronts and manufacturers their palm
oil
um
companies
my
these people are poor and are clearly
ill-equipped to take on drug gangs
developers or businessmen
the inter-american human rights
commission ruled in 2015 that all the
land taken from the garifuna
has to be returned to them fact is
hardly any has been
and crucially none that's on the
beachfront and of course that is where
developers want to build hotels on land
that these people consider sacred
[Music]
it may have been hundreds of years ago
but being evicted once has left this
community determined to make sure it
doesn't happen again
surviving off the land and the sea is
just about possible
but a sustained attack on their natural
resources their environment
and their people could see this
vulnerable group
shattered once more mr ramsey sky news
honduras